notre grande série les meilleures choses
ont une fin c'était aujourd'hui la
séparation pour les 10 membres
d'équipage du complexe spatial américano
russes atlantis mire parmi lesquels le
français jean françois clervoy
commentaires patrice pollet
cet après midi jean françois clervoy a
emprunté une dernière fois le sas de
liaison pour passer de mire atlantis est
et puis derrière le français où on a
tout simplement fermé la porte ensuite
les revois l'équipage d'atlantis sont
partis se couche
7 heures de sommeil avant la séparation
prévue tard dans la soirée mais avant de
regagner la terre ensemble ils ont
répondu aux questions des journalistes
simplex mondial avec houston au texas
moscou et paris au siège de l'agencé
spatiale européenne
comment se passe votre séjour dans la
station elle a connu quelques problèmes
techniques ya même où le feu à bord
alors dites nous la vérité est elle en
bon état ou est elle dans une situation
critique
faut dire que l'équipage a très bien à
ranger les objets qui en général sont un
peu plus lent départ on a trouvé une
station en fait une maison très large et
très accueillante
et puis elle une colline sa procédait à
la distribution gratuite des t-shirts
pour ceux qui restent dormir de beaux
tee shirt avec imprimée sur le tissu le
logo de ce mot
hier voir apportera des émotions fortes
de l'espace
comme cette marseillaise
envoyés depuis houston en son honneur